le singe le fait de montrer ce gobelet
pour m inquiéter je pourrais être
inquiété pour montrer la légalisation du
cannabis
si vous le faites de sang vous avez
selon dell pourrait également jouer des
extensions vers 700 l'instrumentalise
passionnel loin des émotions verbal
alors merci d'être haïku françois michel
lambert çà çà çà c'est l'image qui a le
plus tourné depuis 24 heures
bref vous le faire un coup de com où
c'est un peu des deux voilà permettez
moi d'avoir cyril oui malheureusement on
a appris que sa mort d'un policier qui
est justement été en opération
anti-drogue avignon exactement après
avoir été blessées d'après midi il est
décédé et donc qu'on prenne le temps de
penser à ces assises ont ramassé femme
est évidemment lutte contre notamment le
trafic de cannabis et c'est bien le sens
de ma conscience de votre démarche hier
exactement et on pousse vraiment à la
famille de ce policier on pense à tous
tous les policiers
voilà qui voit des drames s'enchaîner
les uns après les autres et je les dis à
bruno attal il ya un instant bien
entendu qu on s'insurge quand il ya nous
sommes d'avoir des bavures des vrais
ladd et des policiers qui se comporte
mal mais en général on est à ses droits
avec la police est vraiment ce genre de
drame
je peux vous dire que ça ça nous met
dans un état de nerfs et c'est vrai ces
associations c'est incroyable en ce
moment ce qui se passe autour des
policiers
ça nous fait beaucoup beaucoup de peine
ça nous retourne voilà je vous dis et
vous avez raison d'en parler parce que
en vrai c'est ce que vous voulez vous
voulez une légalisation du cannabis en
france vous l'a arrêté voilà vous
critiquez la prohibition du cannabis
hier c'est vrai que votre geste a
énormément fait parler c'est un geste
mal acquis c'est un geste médiatique qui
vous vous êtes dit tout le monde va en
parler ça peut peut-être faire bouger
les choses c'est ça alors tout à fait
d'abord je suis porteur d'une
proposition de loi qui est la
légalisation encadrée de cannabis sous
monopole d'état c'est pas pour faire du
business mais c'est pour reprendre la
main sur le cannabis
cette proposition de loi a été débattu à
l'assemblée nationale le 31 mars dans la
nuit du 31 ans sur le sommaire avril
vous en aviez entendu parler oui bien
sûr mais quand même parlé dans mes en
btp
mais grâce à mon geste on en parlait
beaucoup plus oui c'est vrai et c'est
pour ça qu'il ya eu ce geste c'est pour
nous devons agir sur ce problème de
cannabis sur ce problème de trafic sur
les sur le fait que 1 millions de
consommateurs aujourd'hui ils ont quoi
mais des produits frelatés puisque ce
sont des trafiquants qui leur donnent
souvent ces mêmes mélange et des pneus
avec d'autres choses et puis de l'autre
côté nous avons nos policiers avec le
drame de ce soir mais c'est tous les
jours qu'ils sont face à ce drame les
policiers à courir après très souvent
pas grand chose on a vu sur les réseaux
sociaux parfois que c'était un pain de
savon
là où ils pensaient guêtres de la résine
et c'est ça qu'il faut arrêter d'autres
pays nous aurons alors pour la
légalisation du cannabis parce que y'a
plein de il ya plein de voix là de
raisons pour lesquelles on peut être
pour les amis non mais sur le geste de
notre député tout à ça parce que
évidemment que c'est un coup de com ce
que vous avez fait parce que votre nom
nous était même à ceux qui aiment la
politique à peu près inconnu pardonnez
moi si je suis insultante à votre regard
mais c'est pas le butin c'est simplement
vous dire que on vous connaissait pas
plus que ça avec effectivement depuis
votre nom et est plus connu et on rentre
pas visiblement enfin ce geste là vous
dites maintenant on a parlé du débat
mais non on a parlé du geste on n'a pas
parlé du fond du sujet et que et
qu'effectivement moi je pense qu'on a
vous avez raison non mais c'est un vrai
débat et ça n'aura rien à parler du fond
du sujet mais la laverie
excusez moi de vous dire ça tout mon
respect franchement il n'allait pas il
avait pas s'attarder ce qu'il a fait
hier au contraire c'est ce qu'a mis en
lumière sa loi et c'est pour ça qu'on en
parle aujourd'hui de la stampa non non
non non mais sur la forme permet de
parler du fond a bien furet non ce sont
les images aujourd'hui de buzz bresse il
fait de la politique quand on veut faire
passer ses idées quand on veut véhiculer
ses idées c'est important d'avoir des
gestes forts ils à fargo ou non n'a
brandi ce joint personnes en auraient
parlé aujourd'hui on consacre du temps à
ça et il est là pour parler du fond et
ce qui est bien c'est qu'il a un vrai
discours d'ailleurs c'est pas juste pour
faire du buzz
un bilan bien sûr moi je suis d'accord
avec vous mais moi je trouve franchement
je trouve que votre geste en tout cas je
peux pas dire que je suis d'accord ou
pas avec vous mais en tout cas c'est ça
ça le lendemain le faire parler vous
d'être un symbole et de dire 'voilà
auchan henry on dépénalise voilà les
loups les débris lieu de transit où le
débat n'aurait pas eu lieu je suis pas
du tout d'accord avec vous aller rider
il n'aurait jamais été là aujourd'hui on
en aurait jamais parlé dans touche pas
en bosses s'il avait fait ça pourtant
tant que député il doit être exemplaire
il a il fait un geste
hors la loi oui oui batailleur richard
ferrand était un petit peu énervé
moi je sors par la loi c'est ce que je
vais faire ce soir tu vas faire parce
que c'est pas le mégot mais c'est plutôt
d'avoir un objet je vous laisse
essaimant gobelet pour la légalisation
du cannabis je sais que ce que je pose
là devant vous vous valoir vis-à-vis du
csa a des problèmes on a juste un
gobelet en grèce disant la légalisation
voilà où en est la france dans tous les
autres pays ont une autre relation
cannabis qui permet entre la
dépénalisation et la légalisation donc
nous devons repenser complètement la
page étant pour l'instant c'est pourri
bo passe à la dernière partie s'il vous
plaît merci ni d'ondine tu peux te
réveiller merci à sa dernière partie
nasri gilles moi je reconnais que vous
créez le débat bah oui bon c'est un très
joli coup mais sur le fond je ne vous
comprends pas vous êtes député vous
représenter les français vous dit c'est
pas pour faire du business mais si vous
avez dit texto la drogue va créer des
emplois et des recettes fiscales c'est à
dire non mais vous renoncez à la lutte
vous renoncez à la lutte contre le
cannabis risque de dépression produits
toxiques morlaàs ne le ferez quoi
répondait vert c'est tout l'inversé
tout d'abord c'est un monopole d'état
donc déjà c'est pas du business comme
tout le reste
d'ailleurs certains me critique là
dessus pour ce que vous dites
aujourd'hui c'est un million de
personnes tous les jours 5 millions qui
sont face à des produits extrêmement
toxique puisque ils sont frelaté il sera
au niveau de thc
enfin grâce à l'argent de la fiscalité
nous aurons des moyens pour beaucoup
plus de prévention
de toute façon où ça y est j'ai
travaillé avec énormément de policiers
énormément de médecins énormément de
spécialistes avec des experts de les
autres pays du monde et il n'y a plus
aucun pays au monde censée qu'ils soient
dans la prohibition
donc ce geste permet ce soir d'expliquer
que la légalisation elle va arriver un
jour je pense même dans deux trois ans
malgré les propos de de nombreux
candidats à la présidentielle ce sera
légalisée parce que quand vous aurez
l'espagne l'italie la suisse la suisse
le luxembourg la belgique l'allemagne
qui ont légalisé ou à peu près qu'est ce
que vous ferez en france une politique
qui n'existera pas saisie jamais on
n'aura députés et des magasins de cbd
parti socialiste on va dans les bureaux
de tabac ya quand même les feuilles avec
les filtres enfin toute l'industrie est
là
tout le monde est prêt il ya juste à
légaliser qui va s'énerver est ce que tu
vas voir là à ce qu'il va voir le camp
mais c'est avec estime à suicide en mai
regretter votre geste ou pas ce que je
veux surtout dire tout ce qui regarde et
je sais que vous avez beaucoup beaucoup
de jeunes le cannabis en dessous de 25
ans c'est dangereux
ce n'est pas un geste doit inciter à la
consommation c'est un geste justement
pour inciter à la précaution à la
prévention ne touchait pas aucun avis
sur tout si vous êtes jeune et si vous
êtes plus âgé soyez extrêmement prudents
avec